I've heard you say composition I've
heard you talk about composition many
times do you just even go like to the
grocery store and you're just like okay
this aisle at Ralph's I'm framing it
here I would do this yeah that was
always a a really big thing for me I
would notice the way things are framed
and like what I deemed is cinematic you
know what I mean and I always felt like
that was one of the weapons and like a
person who is an independent filmmaker
or a content creator versus money I
always felt like that was one of those
tools that could help make your project
better like the way it's lit the way it
sounds and the way that you compose your
shots you know like the term cinematic
like how cinematic can you be even if
you have no money how can we make this
look like a movie like how can we make
this look big how can we make this look
bring as much spectacle to it as you can
even if you don't have very much you
know and yeah so yeah I'm like huge on
composition like I'll be that's the
first thing I noticed when I'm watching
something you know oh you know look at
the composition and look at the way
these actors are framed like why do they
frame this way what are they trying to
say like what you know like yeah I just
dissect movies a lot and even when I
don't want to but even it sounds like in
real and non movie life
you're still dissecting yeah yeah you
know I just I see cinema and everything
like I see art and everything I see
cinema and everything
I can't turn it off you know it's such a
big part of me you know yeah it's it's
one of those things like that just it's
yeah it's just lifting you like you know
and yeah I see so many shots right now
just you know just the way light hits a
person's face and the way the sunlight
comes in creeps into a room like you
know always thinking who those things
you're always noticing those things
you